I guess tonight of the stars the
much-anticipated movie the predator
which is in theaters September 14th
please welcome to cast keegan-michael
key
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to tell you guys first of all I
want to congratulate you a week ago they
let me see a rough rough rough cut of
the movie which I loved but it was also
hilarious because in one or two scenes
key characters like the predator were a
heavy guy in a green suit it took me
right out of the movie for a second but
then I was back in again but that's the
way you should release the movie Shane
you should do it down yes visas to guys
scurry and there'd be a note underneath
that say not done yet yeah the bread
would be like run out and then he'd come
running back in and it was a guy who was
sweating a lot he just didn't run off we
have a lot to talk about Keegan of
course you're a huge comedy star but I
find out today it has always been your
dream to be an action star is that taste
that is true that has always been yes
Thank You composable yes thank you I
want to thank all these people for
helping my dream come true but
especially Shane for writing this
wonderful script yeah with our dear
friend Fred Dekker who is this co-writer
yeah it's Shane black we may as well
what are you gonna do the predator the
predator and Shane Black them exactly we
added Lethal Weapon who created Iron Man
3 who created how do you picture
yourself when you would imagine yourself
as got the job settle down pal I know
but I'm curious how did you picture
yourself fitting into an action role I
mean did you used to imagine this yeah
this is this is literally my dream man I
was a kid a little kid I wanted to I
wanted to be James Bond I liked to work
as go see James Bond movies with my dad
and when I saw the first predator when I
was 16 years old I was like God I mean
this isn't a job I can do I'm not gonna
be able to do this job so it was always
my fantasy to be able to pick up a gun
or a you know and just blow stuff up
yeah and which and so I went to acting
school and then here we are yeah that's
what it takes
you got to go to acting school to go
like this yeah what's your level I'm
told you have a high level of predator
knowledge a pretty high pretty high
level I'm a bit of a nerd I am a big fan
of the yahshua ouch was the species
species they're called the ouch WA and
to become an elder Klan member of the
ouch way you have to start unbloodied as
a youth as a youth you have to go with
two other young yahshua you have to kill
xenomorphs and then you get to be
blooded and then the way to get to the
top echelon is if you kill 3z no more
fries
I don't yeah he just about Mormon yes
[Applause]
you